they're not taking any chances
after nights of unrest and looting shop
owners in this neighborhood in amsterdam
are nervous
i have to barricade my shop every month
already it's been stressful
can we pay our rent or not and now this
comes on top of it
i've also lost my freedom but we just
have to endure this if we stick together
we'll be out of this crisis faster
but for this young man the curfew and
this crisis have become an excuse
to take over the city streets like here
in rotterdam
outnumbered police had to witness how
shops were looted and destroyed
the same happened in a dozen other towns
and cities across the country
the netherlands has had a more relaxed
approach in dealing with the covet 19
pandemic compared to other countries
stressing the dutch are too attached to
their freedoms but with infections still
high and growing concern over new
variants
their corona measures have now become
among the strictest in the world
what started as protests against the
kurds who have quickly turned violent
and chaotic
they may have seen little to do with
corona measures but they might have been
fed
by a growing feeling of distrust against
the government
influenced by conspiracy theories on
social media
some groups have increasingly lashed out
against government policies and
attacked the media far-right politicians
have been accused of fueling these
sentiments
this group of people is getting much
more detached from
the general public and when you look at
international surveys we can also see
that the trust gap between a certain
group of people
is increasing so it's not that this
group is getting
much larger well we can't really say
that this group is a large group but the
trust gap between this group and other
people is
increasing so that's probably something
we should worry about
in a message on social media the
rotterdam mayor directly addressed
rioters
and their parents
how did you wake up did you have a good
feeling that you destroyed the city
that you caused damages to the
entrepreneurs of your city
does that satisfy you and what did you
do with the stuff you stole last night
questions that many are asking in the
netherlands like these shop owners in
amsterdam who are also wondering
why in times of crisis some people
choose to make the situation
even worse step fasten al jazeera
amsterdam